klasse erste bank
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am 30
mai 2020 war es endlich soweit nach
vielen jahren harter arbeit und einigen
fehlschlägen schickt sp6 nun die ersten
beiden astronauten ins weltall zu ss das
war nicht nur ein meilenstein für spacex
sondern für die raumfahrt im allgemeinen
denn es war das erste mal dass
astronauten von einer privat
entwickelten rakete aus in den orbit
geschickt wurden
damit markiert die mission den start
eines neuen zeitalters der raumfahrt
sie symbolisiert die privatisierung aber
auch die vergünstigung von flügen ins
weltall und könnte in der zukunft als
der wendepunkt hin zu einer neuen ära
gelten was sich nun alles ändern wird
darum geht es in diesem video bei doktor
watson
[Musik]
vor neun jahren 2011 schickten die
amerikaner das letzte mal astronauten
von ihrem eigenen land aus ins weltall
das space shuttle programm wurde
eingestellt zu teuer zu riskant seitdem
gab es nur eine möglichkeit zur
internationalen raumstation zu kommen
die sojus-rakete der russischen
weltraumorganisation roskosmos
ausgerechnet vom ehemals großen feind
waren die amerikaner nun abhängig
ungefähr zeitgleich begann das
commercial programm bei dem privat
us-firmen fördermittel in
milliarden-höhe bekamen und raumschiffe
raumkapseln und andere systeme zu
entwickeln mit denen die amerikaner
wieder ins weltall kommen könnten und
mit dabei war natürlich auch spacex sie
entwickelten die crew dragon kapsel eine
möglichkeit menschen auf der eigenen
feld hinein rakete zu transportieren
die kapsel ist bewusst modern designt
worden mit viel freiraum sauberer weißer
innen bekleidung und touchscreens ein
starker kontrast oder art und weise wie
astronauten bisher in der sojus rakete
geflogen sind und eigene weltraumanzüge
wurden auch designed viele maß ist nun
mal mindestens ein genauso großer
showman der geschäftsmann ist das heißt
aber nicht dass alles optimal lief im
april 2009 10 explodierte eine dragon
kapsel bei einem test die ursache dafür
wurde erst monate später gefunden es war
ein fehlerhaftes ventil dass die
explosion auslöste und die ersten report
tests waren ursprünglich schon für 2014
geplant fanden dann aber aus diversen
gründen erst im januar 2020 statt
eine verzögerung nach der anderen hat
das projekt heimgesucht aber nun nach
vielen jahren der hafenentwicklung einem
erfolgreichen bord test und einem flug
zur iss ohne menschen konnten die ersten
beiden astronauten auf einer space
extrakte fliegen
aufgrund des wetters wurde der start am
nur 17 minuten vor dem lift auf
abgebrochen und auf samstag verschoben
bei bemannten missionen gelten einfach
andere sicherheitsvorkehrungen
zum beispiel wird nicht nur das wetter
an der historischen startrampe 39a
gecheckt sondern auch überall dort wo
die astronauten auf ihrem weg ins all
theoretisch landen könnten falls etwas
mit der rakete schief geht
doch am samstag den 30 hat dann endlich
alles geklappt
die beiden astronauten bob bänken und da
curly flogen in ihrem neu designten und
ma
geschneiderten raumanzügen zur iss
parallel dazu konnte die felgen ein
rakete die die beiden in die umlaufbahn
gebracht hat wieder auf einer plattform
im meer landen
je nach schätzung schwarz basics damit
zwischen 40 und 50 millionen dollar weil
sie die rakete jetzt wieder verwenden
können 19 stunden nach dem start in
florida lockten die beiden astronauten
dann an der iss an
ein historischer moment der beweis dass
auch private unternehmen menschen zu
isaf schicken können
damit hat die nasa nun endlich seit 2011
wieder eine möglichkeit unabhängig von
russland astronauten ins weltall zu
bringen
insgesamt kauften die amerikaner in den
letzten jahren 70 tickets zu ss von
roskosmos also von russland
zusammengerechnet etwa 3,9 milliarden us
dollar dabei sind die kosten pro platz
in den letzten jahren immer weiter
angestiegen
zuletzt kostete ein einzelner platz 2 ss
etwas über 80 millionen dollar
kein wunder also dass die nasa in
private raumfahrtunternehmen spacex und
boeing investiert hat denn auch boeing
arbeitet gerade an einer neuen kapsel
für die etwas ältere atlas 5 rakete in
den nächsten jahren könnte es also dann
drei möglichkeiten geben bemannte
mission zur iss zu fliegen wo es bisher
nur eine gab nur dürfte klar sein
welchen service die nasa in zukunft
bevorzugen wird während ein platz im
starliner von boeing ganze 90 millionen
dollar kosten wird spielt space extra
selber 55 millionen an einer der gründe
hierfür ist wie gerade schon gesagt das
space extrakten wiederverwenden kann
das zeitalter der privaten raumfahrt hat
also begonnen während space sex und
erfolgreich die ersten astronauten zur
iss gebracht hat will boeing bald mit
dem starliner nachziehen und das private
raumfahrtunternehmen blue origin von
amazon gründer jeff bezos hat darüber
hinaus insgesamt knapp 580 millionen
dollar förderung für die rückkehr zum
mond bekommen
sie sollen einen bemannten luna länder
entwickeln und bauen der astronauten auf
den mond bringen und die erste stufe
einer mondbasis sein soll
doch wollen sich die unternehmen in
zukunft nicht nur auf die fördergelder
vom staat verlassen
die raumfahrt soll auch für private
kunden und investoren geöffnet werden
ein flug ins all wird bei den preisen
wohl erstmal nur sehr wenigen menschen
vorbehalten sein
aber spacex hat bereits angekündigt
diesen wenige menschen gerne zu helfen
wenn sie den zahlen und sogar die nasa
zeigt interesse daran die iss für
private und kommerzielle missionen zur
verfügung zu stellen
zum beispiel soll ein film mit tom
cruise auf der iss gedreht werden
mit wem auch sonst space ex könnte dabei
den transport dass promis übernehmen und
hat sogar konkrete pläne schon nächstes
jahr zusammen mit dem amerikanischen
raumfahrtunternehmen astrium space den
ersten vollständig privaten bemannten
flug zur iss durchzuführen extrem space
wurde vom ehemaligen nasa
programmdirektor der ss michael
suffredini gegründet und der hat mit
seiner firma noch viel größere ziele er
will zum beispiel auch die erste
kommerzielle raumstation bauen
vielleicht werde vor dem also in zukunft
noch einiges mehr hören wir stehen also
vor einer möglichen revolution der
gesamten raumfahrt mit dem umstieg auf
private unternehmen ergeben sich eine
menge neuer möglichkeiten und ziele
gleichzeitig stelle sich aber auch viele
neue fragen zum beispiel wie geht es mit
der zusammenarbeit zwischen nasa und
roskosmos weiter seit das space shuttle
programm 2011 eingestellt wurde
entwickelte sich ein vertrautes
verhältnis zwischen den beiden
raumfahrtagenturen mann war voneinander
abhängig die einen brauchen die sitze
auf der sojus kapsel die anderen
brauchen das geld auch die politischen
konflikte der letzten jahre konnten die
gemeinsame arbeit an der iss nicht
wirklich erschüttern
mit der erfolgreichen show dragon
mission von spacex ändert sich jetzt
aber einiges die usa ist russland nun
was die technologie der raumkapseln und
die kosten für starts angeht meilenweit
voraus und vor allem unabhängig von
russland
das ist für roskosmos ein enormer
finanzieller rückschlag die aufträge der
nasa allein im jahr 2018 haben laut
gelegt der dokumente knapp 17 prozent
des gesamten budgets von roskosmos
ausgemacht dieser anteil fällt jetzt
einfach weg auch die frage nach dem
fokus der zukünftigen als es missionen
ist nicht unwichtig wird die als es teil
der kommerziellen raumfahrt dann könnte
es sein dass die kunden mit dem größten
budget darüber entscheiden woran dort
oben geforscht wird und es ist nicht
garantiert dass diese forschungen dann
auch im interesse aller sind
hier sollte man sich also besser früher
als später gedanken machen wie
verhindert werden kann dass private
investoren die richtung vorgeben und
wichtige vorstellungen für die
allgemeinheit auf der strecke bleiben
insgesamt bleibt abzuwarten was für vor
und nachteile die kommerzielle raumfahrt
mit sich bringen wird und auch wie das
neue kräfteverhältnis zwischen amerika
und russland aussehen wird es ist zum
beispiel wahrscheinlich dass die
einsatzzeiten der sojus rakete in den
nächsten jahren immer weiter abnehmen
und vielleicht ist ja sogar russland
irgendwann von amerika abhängig um
astronauten zur iss zu bringen
in jedem fall hoffe ich dass sowohl
naser als auch aus kosmos in den
nächsten jahren im ziel vereint bleiben
zusammen mit anderen nationen die ss als
menschliche außenposten im weltall
weiterzuentwickeln und die forschung
dort oben voranzutreiben
ich finde die als es zeigt einfach immer
wieder dass es trotz politischer
streitigkeiten ziele gibt die uns als
menschheit vereinen und die ein staat
oder eine firma alleine so nie erreicht
hätten und das lässt einen doch positiv
in die zukunft blicken
irgendwie dreht sich immer alles um die
usa und russland wenn es um das thema
weltall geht oder habt ihr euch schon
mal gefragt was die anderen länder
gerade so machen indien china und
vereinigte arabische emirate haben
tatsächlich alle ziemlich große ziele
was das weltall angeht super interessant
ist da übrigens auch luxemburg die das
zentrum für spaceys start ups werden
wollen und den asteroiden farming boom
jetzt schon vorher sagen wenn ihr zu
diesem thema also space in ländern die
nicht gerade russland oder usa sind mehr
hören wollt dann könnt ihr gerne auch
petra darüber abstimmen
die alternative dazu ist dass wir ein
video zum thema space shuttle machen
haben wir gerade schon drüber gesprochen
wurde 2011 leider eingestellt und war so
der erste versuch von usability im
weltall
warum das nicht funktioniert hat da wird
mir auch ganz gerne mal video zu machen
und ihr könnt auch darüber abstimmen
welches thema wir machen und sowohl
unseren kanal unterstützen als auch das
team das dahinter steht wie immer
danke fürs zuschauen und abonniert gern
in den kanal wenn ihr keine weiteren
videos zum thema space verpassen wollt
ansonsten bleibt neugierig cedric